okay welcome to uh ee 380 the stanford
uh double the
computer systems colloquium
uh for march uh
uh
march 2nd 2022.
um
the speaker today is dave ditzel
from
esperanto technologies
and he's going to tell us about the new
machine that they have in progress
with
thousands of cores and performance
that's
amazing um i think uh it should be very
interesting
um in any case dave um i'm not going to
tell anybody about you though i i will
say that you started out at
bell labs uh made a number of machines
there went on to uh
to berkeley uh made stuff there went to
sun made stuff there
went to well on and on and on uh
someone i
mentioned that they thought that you
just seem to be making machines on a
great on a regular basis and
it's going to be boring to hear about
your new stuff i don't think so
i think i think it's the sixth talk i've
given for the doubly 380 series for
whatever incarnation it's been i went
back and counted just a little bit so 35
years of presenting the w380
i think i think it's it's marvelous but
the fact is she was never going to bad
talk so i'm looking forward to this
okay you're on
great well uh thanks everybody i see a
lot of familiar names here we're gonna
have some fun today i hope
uh and that we'll be able to go into a
little bit more depth and i can
typically do into a squeeze conference
presentation here
and i'm excited to tell you all about
esperanto's
first main chip there's many more to
come
we're going to talk more about hardware
today than software
accelerating ai is just a giant topic
here
and you know for the software so we can
just get some context i'm going to talk
more about accelerating recommendation
because there's lots of kinds of
things to accelerate machine learning
uh and we're gonna do that uh in a kind
of interesting way rather than kind of a
special purpose chip that's oriented
exactly towards machine learning we're
gonna do it by accelerating uh programs
with over a thousand risk five
processors on a chip
and
with some special enhanced hardware and
architecture so we'll go through that
today we'll take some questions at the
end here
so one of the interesting things is of
all the chips being built today uh we
think we've got the world's highest
performance risk 5 chip
uh in in the sense of putting the most
risk five instructions per second on a
single processor here we have over a
thousand risk five processors on a
single seven nanometer chip and for
those who who follow processors think
about how many processor cores you have
in your in your notebook computer or pad
or even in a server and it's a number a
lot smaller than a thousand typically
maybe less than 30 or something than
that today would be typical
of those we have actually three
different processor types we have a 1088
and you'll see why that number comes
about later of our energy efficient we
call our et minion processors those are
full 64-bit wrist-5 processor cores
uh they're fairly simple in-order cores
uh because we're going for energy
efficiency with these cores
and each of those has its own dedicated
vector tensor unit and i'll go through a
lot of detail on those course today uh
in addition to those energy efficient
cores there are times where we want to
operate standalone and you'd like a very
fairly high performance uh single thread
execution uh and so we have a processor
we've designed at esperanto called their
maxion processor and and those are again
full 64-bit risk five cores but using an
out-of-order pipeline
i've only got one slide on that today
but we'll go over it a little bit uh and
then there's one other core we have
which is this a risc-v processor we use
as a service processor which is a little
bit different
but in addition to cores you you have to
keep the course fed
and so
um given how fast these cores are you
want a lot of on-chip bandwidth we have
over 160 million bytes of on-chip sram
we'll show you how we've architected
that
uh this is a full system on chip as well
and we have interfaces for large
external memory uh again because we're
very power conscious we've used low
power ddr4 xdram
we also have interfaces for flash
because for certain kinds of machine
learning storing stuff in flash turns
out to be very helpful
uh we typically
operate
in a mode where we're an accelerator to
a host in a data center and to talk to
that host cpu whether it be it uh
usually intel or amd we talked to it
over eight lanes of pcie gen4
and you know when we put all this on a
chip it allows a single chip
to generate peak rates of 100 to 200 uh
terra ops per second now again the trick
is not so much to get peak rates which
is what everybody likes to quote but
it's how to get high sustainable rates
of computation and that's what a lot of
this talk will be about today
now
you may have seen people put a lot of
cores on a chip uh but typically when
people try and cram a lot of cores on a
chip you know that chip might be uh
two or three or even 400 watts i think
what's really interesting here is that
we come from a background of low power
techniques and we're able to do this
particularly for running machine
learning recommendation where we expect
to be able to operate the chip using
typically under 20 watts of power so
that's one of the keys to what we're
doing here now with a thousand risk five
processors on a chip you can do a lot of
different things almost any workload
that's parallelizable you could think
about distributing amongst these risk
five cores
but that again is a giant topic to talk
about what we could do here so today i'm
really going to focus on machine
learning recommendation and more
particularly inference with
recommendation there
and part of the reason we focused on
that is one of the
the most important problems for a lot of
hyperscale data center uh customers here
in addition to being a fairly hard
problem in its own right so let's talk
about how we deal with that so what's
first of all what's challenging about
recommendation how is it maybe different
than other kinds of of workloads and why
go after data centers well data centers
is where people buy lots of chips and as
a startup company you want to find
customers who want to buy lots of chips
at once and rather than selling to you
know ten thousand customers each of whom
buy three chips
we thought it'd be a lot easier to start
off with you know targeting just a small
number of data center customers each of
whom could buy a large number of chips
now a lot of these servers that are
running ml workloads that you all use
today and recommendation just so you
know is that when you're in a web
browser and you're visiting somebody's
website you'll see advertising come up
and recommendation is where they may
recommend you want to buy bicycles or
red
shoes or a certain shirt they're basing
that across your personal history and
they will try and recommend particular
advertising to you so this is how they
make a lot of money now uh a lot of this
workload today is run on just standard
x86 processors and those servers tend to
have an empty slot a lot of the time in
in
in our case there was a particular
customer they had one
empty slot available with each x86 cpu
but
in order to serve as an accelerator chip
we had to meet a couple key requirements
first of all you need to be faster than
the host cpu that they already have
right if you want to plug in an
accelerator to that existing system so
that meant we needed to deliver on the
order of a hundred
tera ops to a thousand tera ops peak
rates in order to provide sufficiently
better performance than the x86 cpu
already had
they also had a limited power budget
in this particular case it was less than
about 120 watts
there are other pcie cards and other
systems that have 75 watts
and in particular when you have
thousands of these servers and data
centers i think one of the more
interesting lessons is that they really
wanted these to be air-cooled
and there's a little you'll see a little
uh kind of a footnote here to a
reference for a paper this is to uh a
google paper that talks about how they
had mistakenly tried to do water cooling
in their inference and really regretted
it later and so those references all be
available at the end of the presentation
we can go over those i'll try and
reference those
um and again in looking for data types
people have done all kinds of clever
things you know
you know
five-bit integers or specialized
floating point format but really we had
a lot of feedback when we interviewed
the our potential customers they said
look
just just focus on three data types in
eight
uh which is really great fp16 and fb32
if you invent some other specialized
data type realize you are not the only
company who's going to be selling chips
to us to accelerate machine learning
this is going to be a heterogeneous
environment we have to live with intel
amd nvidia various other people we're
not going to be transcoding data between
one or the other just because you have
some fancy data type
he said look spend all your effort there
don't waste any logic gates on doing
anything else because you'll just be
wasting power for something we're not
likely to use and that's pretty
consistent there's a second paper i
reference here from facebook which says
pretty much the the same thing
how much memory capacity uh the customer
said look um
you need to hold on the accelerator card
on the order of 100 gigabytes if you do
that for most of the inference work we
do you can hold what we need on the
accelerator card
at least the most important part for
holding embeddings weights and
activations
and that's good but you can't fit 100
gigabytes on a chip
per se and so you can while you put that
on the board it's still important to
have memory on die because that can
still be very frequently used and have
much higher bandwidth and they
recommended about 100 megabytes and in
fact at the beginning when we went out
with a proposal from esperanto we were
proposing i think graphcore had 256
megabytes we said oh that's a good idea
and we got pretty consistent advice
saying hey don't waste more than about
100 megabytes with online memory if it
doesn't fit in 100 it's not going to fit
in 256.
so that's why we went with just a little
over 100 megabytes
it was very important to handle both
dense and sparse workloads
so dense workloads you might imagine all
the data fits in a little cache and you
can compute all the time but a lot of
these things are fetching data that's
kind of random in memory uh and
embedding in particular is a lookup of
you know a sparse matrix by dense matrix
multiplication here so you have to be
able to randomly access this hundred
gigabytes and do pretty well with that
it's very easy to build very high
performance machine learning uh and have
very impressive you know
terra ops per watt if you can keep
everything on die
but again for the applications we were
going after uh these large commercial
applications they said look that just
that just isn't possible you've got a
reference 100 gigabyte
so how do you deal with these sparse
workloads and in particular they were
really looking for a programmability
there was a lot of view that a lot of
the hardware they had seen was what they
tended to call overly specialized
hardware okay that's really great
you build hardware that does the inner
loop of resin at 50 but you know nobody
really runs resnet50 as an actual
workload uh the workloads are changing
all the time and they were really
looking for more programmability so if
there's anything to come out of this
talk that i'd like you to uh to think
about uh it's um you know can you you
compete in doing machine learning
acceleration with a general purpose
processor or do you really need
specialized hardware to do it and one of
the challenges esperanto took on is to
prove that you could in fact use general
purpose hardware if you had the right
kind of general purpose hardware and you
built it to be very energy efficient
so we'll visit that at the end so let me
see if i can contrast esperanto's
approach versus
there's so many different ai accelerator
chips so let me over generalize a little
bit here to the ones that tend to be
closer to our space but we see a lot of
approaches that build what i call the
one giant hot chip right and on that
they'll tend to put a lot of array
multipliers whether they're systolic
array multipliers or some other kind
that tends to
be very effective and then they'll put
maybe 10 to 20 more general purpose cpu
cores there
and then connected up over
a very high speed interface uh i mean
something like hbi memory because you
have a limited number of pins to uh to
talk to the dram and so you use all your
power budget there and you'll see a lot
of three or four hundred watt chips uh
or things that are even hotter than that
so our approach was a little bit
different rather than building the
largest chip we built a moderate size
chip
and use multiple of those chips that
still try to fit within the same power
budget so why do we do that well if you
have just one chip with one package you
have a limited number of i o pins you
have a limited amount of memory and a
limited amount of memory bandwidth so if
you use multiple chips
your performance the number of pins you
have the amount of memory and the
bandwidth will all scale up with the
number of chips
if you use array multipliers yeah that
can give you a great resonate 50 score
but it's not really very good with large
sparse memory and you'll find as you go
through multiple layers that the matrix
stops being a nice square shape which
fits on an array multiplier but maybe
your data will get tall and thin and it
doesn't fit so well on the array
multiplier again
on by contrast by using thousands of
general purpose risk 5
cores with tensor accelerators we ended
up with the far more programmable
solution
and
to deal with the large memory latency
when going to that 100 gigabytes we used
a similar technique to what a lot of the
gpus use thousands of threads help with
that large sparse memory latency
if you have a case where you only have
10 to 20 general purpose cores that
really limits the amount of total
parallelism you have so anytime your
problem doesn't fit perfectly onto that
array multiplier you can only fall back
to say a parallelism of 10 cores in
parallel whereas with the esperanto
approach we have the full parallelism of
thousands of cores always available so
so long as your program is
parallelizable and most ai programs are
you can get take advantage of that full
parallelism
and then you know in terms of physical
implementation and circuit techniques uh
most everybody else tend to operate
their chips at standard voltages and as
i'll show you uh coming up we believe
that was not the most energy efficient
place to operate uh instead what we do
at esperanto is we operate the power
hungry portions of the chip at
very low relative voltages and that's
because when you operate transistors at
much lower voltages they actually are
more energy efficient
think of
my analogy often uses you know a car
going down the highway yeah you can have
a car that goes 100 miles per hour but
you're probably using your gasoline more
efficiently if you drive at 30 miles per
hour
same kind of thing happens with
transistors you know most of the
semiconductor fabs you know put a a
nominal standard voltage for a chip that
gives the best performance but that's
not always the most energy efficient
place but why doesn't everybody operate
at a lower voltage then well it turns
out you that's not so easy uh while
lower voltage operation reduces power
you've got to have specialized circuit
techniques and we actually change the
actual architecture of the cpu so that
it would better match what happens at
low voltage in fact a number of the
accelerators out there use approaches
that just aren't amenable to low power
for example they put fairly large
uh caches or memory uh at the first
level and you just can't scale those
down and voltage very well
so given this particular approach we
were going after a certain set of
customers
that said look how much performance can
you put on a single accelerator card
with 120 watt limit and i'm going to use
that as an example today uh to show you
how how our particular solution
approaches that particular problem
although it can be used for other other
problems as well
so if you're gonna we had a physical
limitation with one card we could only
mount six chips and all the dram and
power supplies everything else
on a card so we start off with that
constraint so therefore if you take your
120 watts available divide by six it
means each chip complex has to take less
than 20 watts
so for purposes of this example you know
we assume that about half of the 20 watt
power we have available would be
available for a thousand cores because
we don't get all that 20 watts for our
thousand floors we only got half of that
so that only leaves you about 10
milliwatts per core
so let's compare that and see how much
of a challenge this kind of a problem is
now here's what we typically call the
iron rule of power here your power is cb
squared f plus leakage here and
the c there is the dynamic switching
capacitance it's the capacitance that
inherently a wire has or it's the
capacitance you get by touching
typically most capacitors is the gate of
a transistor although there's a little
bit from uh touching the grain or source
of a transistor as well
the voltage that's just the normal
supply voltage but that's times the
voltage squared uh and times the say the
frequency in megahertz plus leakage and
the leakage it will depend a little on
how you want to operate but uh you know
typically on a modern processor that
will be maybe 30 to 40 most of the time
here
so let's take a look at how hard a
problem this is by looking at say a
generic x86 server cpu you might be
familiar with so we just went to a
typical part and looked at the data
sheet and that was 165 watts
and they were able to support 24 x86
cores
so what that means is you have about
seven watts per core
and if you're running it three gigahertz
uh and voltage we guessed there they
vary a little bit about .85 volts and
you can just back engineer and say well
that means the switching capacitance
would be 2.2 nanofarads
so what was our challenge well we needed
to operate with 10 milliwatts per core
we wanted to run about one gigahertz
we can improve energy efficiency by
operating at roughly half of that
voltage
and what that meant is our switching
capacitance could only be 0.04
nanofarads per core
so that meant we had in order to hit our
goals here to use a general purpose
processor we needed a solution that
could be 700 times better than the
traditional x86 cpu you might be
familiar with
now
by operating at a lower frequency the
power consumed is linear with frequency
so we could pick up a factor of three
there
we pick up a factor of four by operating
at half the voltage but powers related
to the voltage square
but what that meant is that the bulk of
the problem of how to fit into the power
envelope had to come from reducing the
dynamic switching capacitance by almost
a factor of 60.
okay
so reducing the frequency was pretty
easy reducing the voltage that's a lot
more work because you have to use
specialized design techniques and
particularly how you deal with both the
circuits that burn power and your
storage
uh if you want s-rams that operate at
this low voltage those are very special
design technique um and the hardest part
here again was reducing the dynamic
switching capacitance
and that really has has to do with
getting a just a simple design now let's
let's go talk about energy efficiency
for a second here so we've got this 120
watt problem here uh what could we do um
um
so on the the y-axis here i've got the
kind of the energy efficiency in terms
of in in
inferences per second per watt and if we
simply took our
our risk 5 000 cpus and we we stuck our
simplified design
and ran it to say the typically way a
graphics vendor might do which is you
over voltage a little bit if we ran them
at 0.9 volts
in seven nanometer
the chip that i'm going to talk to you
about today would have taken about uh
275 watts so clearly over the power
budget if we reduce the voltage to the
nominal voltage in seven nanometer 0.75
watts you can see it still doesn't fit
not
one single chip that is too much we can
start reducing the voltage until we just
barely fit and that would have been
about 0.65 volts and you can see we're
operating a little more energy
efficiency there there but
if you operate at the most energy
efficient point
four seven nanometer transistors from
tsmc
they you get your peak energy efficiency
when operating between 300 and maybe 350
millivolts
and that entire chip with a thousand
processors would then only take about
eight and a half watts
so that when you multiply by six would
in fact have fit within the power budget
and in fact that would have been 20
times more energy efficient by operating
at that low voltage point rather than
the high voltage point
for the machine learning recommendation
benchmark that we're that we're using
now notice also that it's two and a half
times more performance
by using those six chips rather than
using one very hot chip and so that
sounds pretty good however we're not
using up the full 120 watt limit and so
for the server power guys
they say look don't exceed this number
but certainly go ahead and use up the
full power budget and so if we use 20
watts per chip
we'd end up actually having four times
more performance than the single chip
performance would have been
um
and and been still a pretty good energy
efficiency here
so this is why for esperanto we kind of
targeted our sweet spot to be around 0.4
volts
and again our chip is capable of
operating at a variety of operating
points anywhere we're just we're
we believe will be robust all the way
down to about 0.3 volts but you might
want to operate as much as maybe a 0.5
volts but again you're going down the
energy efficiency point there are some
customers that really care about energy
efficiency as i said the primary
customer going after is the one that
simply wants the most inferences per
second that fit in that
power limit of 120 watts but there'll be
other customers simply say hey i don't
care what the power is put on the
biggest heat sink run it up at 300 watts
and so we could choose to do that as
well with our part
so uh how did we build the simplest
possible risk 5 to get that switching
capacitance down so that's what we call
our et minion part um it's a custom
64-bit risk 5 processor
again in order pipelines tend to be more
energy efficient
but to run with a decent speed at low
voltage we had to work very hard to
reduce the number of gates per clock so
we could still get to roughly that
gigahertz level at roughly that 0.4 volt
of operation so we did a lot of
of cross optimization across
the design domains between architecture
and circuits and physical design in
order to enable this low voltage
operation
the the cpu implements the full
risk 5 integer 64-bit instruction set uh
including compressed instructions uh we
have two hardware threads of execution
uh and one of the tricks we've done is
we've made our level one data cache be
able to operate as a scratch pad as well
as a data cache and i'll explain how we
utilize that
in the future
you can see on the right hand side here
roughly to scale
how much area each of the particular
units take
and again the common wisdom is oh if you
use the general purpose instruction set
that would take too much area you
couldn't use that but what you see is in
yellow where the integer pipeline is
that's really not a very large part of
the total
area of one individual processor
most of the areas taken up by the vector
and tensor unit
and in fact the hardest thing in that
vector tensor unit are the 32-bit and
16-bit floating point multiply and
accumulates you can see in purple here
there's a unit here called the tema
that's the tensor integer multiply and
accumulate and again integers much
simpler to do you'll see a lot of
acceleration chips that just do integer
only because floating point is is fairly
hard here
uh and on the vpu register file we
support both threads
something that's a little bit unusual
one of the extensions we did is we
actually do support certain transient
instructions because that was important
for machine learning so we can do vector
transcendentals as well
the floating point operates 5 12 bits
wide for the integer side
but a little bit unusual as we operate
only 256 bits wide for the floating
point and that's because the customer
directly requested kind of a ratio of
float to int here
and so that ended up with a slightly
unusual design uh here where you have a
lot more processing event we can do
128 8-bit integer operations per cycle
in the vector unit and those 8-bit ops
accumulate to 32-bit integers
for floating point
we operate 256 bits wide per cycle and
you can use either 32-bit uh double
single precision or 16-bit
half-precision operations
you get twice as many uh
half precision operations per cycle and
then you can you'll be accumulating
those uh
for the half precision you can
accumulate either in half precision or
into a 32-bit single position per cycle
uh one of the things that's a little bit
different in the extension we've done as
well is we've added multi-cycle tensor
instructions
so a tensor is when you're multiplying
say a matrix times another matrix here
and that occurs very frequently in
machine learning so what we can do is
operate at the full width of 512 bits
and we can run for up to 512 cycles
with one of these tensor instructions so
you might do as many as 32 000
arithmetic operations with one single
tensor instruction
well why did we do that well it reduces
the instruction fetch bandwidth
tremendously and that also helps reduce
power so when you think of multiplying
you know two matrices by each other
rather than it being in a general
purpose program loop that might take a
lot of power fetching instructions
running the integer pipeline we have a
very tiny finite state machine that
operates the tensor and we actually put
the risk 5 integer pipeline to sleep
during tensor operations
and what you'll see when you're running
very high performance machine learning
workloads you might be spending 99 95 of
your time in tensor instructions so
again we reduce the overhead or the cost
for using general purpose programming to
a negligible amount
so we can provide a very nice
programming environment but we get the
kind of efficiencies you would get by a
a very highly optimized hardwired
vector unit
because that's where you're spending
almost all your time
we can operate our our
minion anywhere from around 300
megahertz to perhaps up to uh to two
gigahertz um and so
uh each individual minion cpu can
deliver a peak performance of 128 giga
ops per gigahertz
uh now
the the way we've optimized the design
is is with a core that's really designed
for parallel programming and so what we
realize is in the physical design
limitation in seven nanometer you can
only go a certain distance in your clock
cycle and so we found that we could pack
about eight cpus together
um
uh
in this proximity and so we call that a
computing neighborhood
and we're able to capitalize on that
physical proximity for running parallel
code so for example
um
when you're running code on a thousand
processors you'll tend to find that
they're almost always running the same
code there's you have a highly parallel
problem you're multiplying giant
matrices you give each processor a piece
of that matrix to go off and work on
right so rather than having many
separate instruction caches that each
had redundant code in them
we in groups of eight have a common
shared instruction cache so that
tremendously increased the capacity we
can have in the instruction cache and
because we have tensor instructions that
are used very frequently the fetch
bandwidth is actually not very high so
we can share that one instruction cache
amongst eight minions
uh and and not have any uh
large performance hit we do a similar
trick with the uh on the data cache side
what you'll tend to find is a lot of the
time the processors are all loading
something from the same address
from the l2 cache into the l1 cache
and that's a very power intensive
operation so if you were to do eight
individual loads one for each
uh risk 5 minion
you'd have eight times that amount of
power but with the feature we call a
cooperative load when all of the loads
are there pending when the first
processor goes out and fetches it the
other seven processors are waiting and
they simply capture the data that's come
back off the l2 bus back to this group
of uh eight cpus in a neighborhood and
and that was just a dramatic savings in
power
um
um you know compared to not having that
type of instruction so that's an example
where
you can't just go and pick an
off-the-shelf risk five processor and
put it down and expect to get the levels
of energy efficiency
sorry
okay
so cooperative loads were very helpful
and there are a number of kinds of
instructions we do to make cooperation
uh more efficient here we have
instructions for fast synchronization
we have instructions to send to a
neighbor receive from neighbor and i'll
go through some of those extensions a
little bit later in the talk
okay
um
so uh how do we then group these so now
we have a group of eight in the prior
slide what we do is we take four of
those eight core neighborhoods and we
pack them into what we call a minion
shire we uh we wanted a little grouping
of large what's larger than a
neighborhood but smaller than a city and
we tried various groupings here so when
shire we have a lord of the rings fan uh
shires what we ended up with here uh and
so we have we next we build groups of 32
cpus together now with the group of 32
we put a much larger amount of memory we
put four megabytes of memory together
with four banks interconnected with a
four by four crossbar
and that will let us load enough data
that we can keep these cpus busy
crunching on that particular data and
keep them fed so again they can get
higher sustained rates of performance
and we're able to feed them at that rate
the the these srams can be configured
uh as a level two cache
or as a level three cache or as a
scratch pad there are certain times
where your workloads are very
deterministic
and you do not want to have cache
thrashing or other things going on so if
you configure them as a scratch pad you
can pretty much guarantee that the data
will be there waiting for you when
you're ready and somebody else some
other processor will not have thrown it
out of the cache
these groups of 32 are interconnected
with an on-chip network we just call it
a mesh stop i'll show you how that's
interconnected next
uh
again within a shire you can use some of
these new synchronization primitives
we've added to the risk 5 instruction
set
atomic operations barrier instructions
credit counters and inter processor
interrupt support
so here's maybe a good place for you to
understand how we've worked in our power
saving through operating at different
voltages so you can see these groups of
32 et minions they all operate on a
single low voltage plane
even the data caches are built out of
special
memory cells we use instead of a typical
6t cell a 12t transistor cell
so those can operate down to 300
millivolts but when you want very dense
amounts of memory
the rule in designing velocity chips is
you always want to use the densest cell
from your memory bender they have
optimized that
many ways they do lots of special tricks
and you you really want to operate that
and pretty much the nominal voltage
and so again you'll see we have two
different voltage domains in this
particular unit and we have many
different voltage domains across our
chip and that lets us go in and tweak
each voltage domain
particularly for the neighborhoods the
lowest voltage for best energy
efficiency
and then you adjust your
your um
large des end srams to kind of meet the
speed that you need to to match that and
a voltage that's very close to the
nominal voltages
okay so now we have to make these shires
talk to each other and that's done over
a mess stop with um
i say large amounts of parallelism we
use lots of wires and those wires run at
the low voltages uh and so what you'll
find is is uh there are for example from
one mesh top uh say on the left to a
neighbor on its right
there will be several thousand wires in
a unidirectional bus going from one mesh
top to the other and several thousand
wires coming back the other direction
and this is one of the beauties of using
a technology like seven nanometers the
wires are very small and you can put
many
hundreds of thousands of wires for
getting high on-chip bandwidth on a chip
for interconnectivity
um so then let's put everything together
here so we have our shires with groups
of 32 you can see kind of in the center
here we have an array of a six by six
array
we use 34 of those shire positions to
put groups of 32 processors and that's
how we end up with our 1088
we needed to use kind of two of those
groupings at the top right for some
other things we put four of our maxion
cpus in the shire at the upper right
along with a risk 5 service processor
and then we have to have logic for our
pcie bus interface
for
dft fuses and those are what we call a
pcie shire
on the
in this block diagram roughly
corresponds to the physical layout on
the chip on the that we call the east
and the west sides we have dram
controllers here and in order to provide
the
uh the bandwidth we want but with very
low power for low power we use the low
voltage swing lpddr 4x vram but we go
256 bits wide
so on the east side for example we do
128
bits wide that's by using 16-bit wide
controllers and just using multiple of
those that connect upon the chip okay so
that gives you then a picture of how the
memory is distributed across the chip
how the processes are distributed across
the chip and how they connect to memory
okay and so the the processors on a chip
are all sharing a single global address
space
so when a processor let's say in the
lower left wants to request a piece of
data it'll first ask and see if it's in
its local l1 data cache it's not there
it goes out to the l2 cache and it's
memory shire and that's kind of the l2s
are kind of private to the shire if it's
not there it queries the l3 cache
subsystem the l3 subsystem operates
across the entire die and so that piece
of data may be in any shires l3 cache if
it's in your own
shire you get it a little bit quicker if
not you make hops out to put the request
out and the shire that has the data on
die we'll send it back to you
and it may seem like it's a lot of hops
if you're in the if your data was in the
top right shire and you want to consume
it in the lower left shirt but let me
tell you that's still a lot faster than
going off chip to uh off off-chip dram
so overall
it's what you might think of as almost a
fairly conventional memory system with
l1 l2 l3 caches and main memory
so people who are used to programming
super computers
take a look at this design and go oh i
understand how to use that
fairly easy to map problems onto this
kind of a structure
and again while we've done a six by six
array here because of this fairly
modular design think of this first chip
as the prototype it's going to be fairly
easy for us to scale this down if we
want to go to edge devices or to scale
it up in the future to much larger
arrays and at the end of the talk we'll
speculate a little bit on what those
larger things might look like in in
future products
without making any actual product
announcement here's just a little bit
more detail to show you that this really
is a system on a chip we have all kinds
of other interfaces uarts flash
interfaces gpios
timers um
interfaces for debuggers usb
and so this can operate as a stand-alone
chip at times uh but you know quite
often in our first customer uses uh
we'll be talking across the pcie bus
um
to a a host uh host processor
for data center customers they very much
care about security so we have a route
of trust
for providing secure boot
um
and there's a lot of redundancy built in
here
typically for example we have enough
compute shires here that we can use one
as a fully redundant one uh one to
control the other shires and have a nice
round number of a thousand for the
software to use uh so there's a lot of
redundancy and uh
opportunities to
very have fine grain control over
individual positions on the chip and
i'll talk a little bit more about that
we do have full ecc support both in the
dram and in the internal memory system
as well
so how do we use this in practice well
again if you can get the power per chip
down that means when the customer wants
to say how much performance do you get
on a board it really we need to compare
the performance on a board here not just
an individual chip so what you can see
here is if we think about having six
chips mounted on the board our memory
system is really a 1500 bit wide memory
system here we can put up to 192
gigabytes of accelerator memory using 24
uh dram packages each 64 bits wide um
those 64-bit wide packages actually tend
to have two 32-bit wide drams in a
single package here
uh so you see we can get a lot of memory
here to get a lot going and what you
want to do is have a lot of channels
each one of those 64-bit wide drams is
actually made up of four 16-bit channels
so we end up having 96 of these 16-bit
channels able to operate in parallel
here
and remember we have two threads per
core so with all over a thousand
threads per chip on one board we get
over 12 000 threads of execution going
at one time with this memory system and
then those will connect through a pci
switch to the host
so let's take a picture of what a look
at one of those cars might be like
here are
six
chips in a
mock-up module here that fit on an uh
ocp glacier point v2 card
and it can handle
um you'll see there are what's called a
dual mdot ii module on the top uh you
can handle three on the top and three on
the bottom so this card you see in the
background in red is just kind of a
standard card and you could plug
for example you can turn this into a
solid-state disk i believe facebook has
some parts they've
worked with qualcomm on that do uh video
decoding uh or if you use our chip you
could plug it in and be accelerating uh
ai applications here
um
and so one card here
in that power limit we believe can
provide over 800 tera ops uh when all
six chips are are operating at a
gigahertz
so how do you use that card well
think of think of that in our customers
this way
so we put six chips on a standard pcie
interface card that can drop into what's
called the yosemite v2 sled
and that yosemite system has it's
actually a dual x86 cpu system so it has
two pcie slots available as well so we'd
be putting 12 chips in that you then put
four of those yosemite systems in what
they call a cubby right so now we're up
to putting 48 chips in the cubby and
then those go into a rack and you can
hold eight of these yosemite cubbies in
a rack
so we get 384
chips in a rack
and then some of these large data
centers have as many as 20 000 racks in
a single hyperscale data center so our
customer opportunity here is to sell
millions of chips
to just one particular data center and
some of our customers operate many of
these large-scale data centers and of
course there's many customers that have
this so that's kind of the business
model we had to get started for why we
decided to pick going after data centers
there are other places you want to uh go
into as well and so we do have other
form factors so for example uh
we can put you know one or several of
our chips on standard pcie express cards
as well
okay let's talk just a little bit about
software and then the instruction sets
here um
so most of our customers we think will
program a recommendation models uh using
something like pie torch you may use
some
machine learning framework and we can
get to most of the frameworks here
through onyx models
we started off
our initial software was based on the
glow system that facebook initially
started and then has open sourced that
was nice because it it
provided for partitioning of models
across multiple chips
and had a fairly clean
separation of the machine dependent
versus the machine
independent parts so on the machine
dependent part we went in and were able
to change the back end to generate code
for our particular cpu
then we provided our own run time and
our own etpcie driver for the host and
that lets us again you know bring in any
of these particular sources run it
through glow and run it on our hardware
we're also doing a tv import that seems
to be gaining in popularity uh and again
we expect we'll have other software uh
in the future here
so that's kind of a simple view of the
software um
i know people are kind of curious about
what we've done to extend risk five uh
we have added a number of vector and
tensor instructions uh
uh
i'll give some examples in these these
little blue squares here for different
vector ops we can you know not only have
computation but there's conversion we do
uh scatter gather again for people are
used to programming super computers
that's kind of a natural people
understand how to do that we have
transcendental vector operations
uh
not just computation but also
communication so we can broadcast
do special kinds of loads and stores
with inner leaves trans
poses reduces transformations
and again controlling the memory system
is key for keeping high sustained rates
we have some special cash control
operations we put in these barrier
credits atomic operations cash
trigger cash control operations and how
you reserve space in the scratch pad
these were all things we did when we
kind of started on risk five and said
look we have to think about this in kind
of a super computer mentality we're
starting with a thousand processors on a
chip this is kind of like a lot of
data centers that use small number of
cores but they have a thousand cores in
their whole data center here
um
and so with the tensor multiply
operations we can uh multiply you know
two-dimensional matrices or
three-dimensional matrices here for what
we're doing i won't spend a lot of time
on the detail here but let me just show
you an example of how we use these new
instructions so if you think of starting
off with our little block diagram here
we have a thousand cores one of the
first things you might do is a tensor
load the l2 scratch pad and so what this
will do is it'll take uh data that's
maybe out in dram or it might possibly
be in some of the l3s or a mixture of
the two and it will it will bring it
into a particular shires into those four
megabytes of memory into the amount
you've allocated for scratch pad and
those you can
allocate those in different size
partitions kind of at will here
once it's in that
l2 scratch pad
then what you'll do is to do a tensor
load instruction and that will load from
the scratch pad memory the large
four megabyte capacity into the
individual e.t minions into their local
data caches
once you have the data in the data
caches you want to operate on
then you can go and you execute the
actual floating point multiply
accumulate tensor instruction and so
that'll move data into the vector
register files and the floating point
units directly
and then store the results back in the
vector register file and then we have
instructions which do the reverse to get
things back out to memory as well why so
many instructions why didn't we just
have one instruction and stream all this
in like everybody else well
programmers are have gotten very clever
over the last 20 years in figuring out
how to
overlap the data movement so you can
keep high sustainable rates of
computation
again although everybody quotes peak
rates
the goal really is to get high
sustainable rates of computation and so
again there's there's sort of there's a
wealth of expertise here on how to keep
high sustainable rates if you're using a
more traditional programming model here
and that's what we've done and we're
very happy with how that works out
so uh with what we've done our tensor
fma operation we are keeping this near a
hundred percent utilization over the 512
cycles that it runs we can keep the
machine you know it's how do you keep
the beast fed how do you keep all these
anal use fed on the machine here
so we're able to uh to do that and again
each tensor instruction in this
particular example might do 16 000
floating point operations all from one
one risk 5 extended instruction issue
here and again the risk 5 integer core
gets put to sleep during these long
tensor operations so that saves on on
power overall
the integer uh
8-bit integer uh tensor operations are a
little bit different um
in that we have a separate integer
register file uh that assists the
generic
uh vector register file in these
operations here uh so that we get uh
four times the throughput that we get
from fv16 when we're doing integer
operations and of course we do standard
tricks like you know if you're going to
do a multiply check to make sure if
you're multiplying by zero
don't toggle your gates you know the
answer is going to be zero just pass the
zero on and go through and do that
we have a number of instructions here
for coordination
special barrier instructions credit
counters
uh and there's a little again a lot of
little programming tricks the the
programmers can can utilize to keep high
throughput in the machine here so let's
get to some benchmarks here so how do we
do
so we're trying to figure out a way to
you know
give a fair comparison between what we
thought we would do
since
most of the
recommendation work was going on on
intel cpus today
we decided to use the intel cpu as a
reference
um and for benchmarkings we're very much
fans of the ml perf consortium here and
they have a deep learning recommendation
benchmark that they put in so we're
using that
why because as we've learned in
benchmarking it's more fair if you let
that vendor cite their own performance
on their best configuration rather than
you running it and not getting the
parameters right
so the performance numbers i'm getting
here let's say for the you know the on
the xeon 3000 samples per second per die
this comes directly out of going to the
perf website
taking the absolute best performance
chip they can utilize and the best
system they have with the best amount of
memory and we just use those numbers
right
so you can see that intel has picked a
fairly high performance chip for just
eight chips they're burning two
kilowatts just for the cpus alone so
that's they're operating at roughly 250
watts per die
uh and they get reasonable performance
with that
nvidia would say hey our gpus are better
and in fact they are
in terms of relative
performance they're 11 times better in
absolute performance
and if you look at the amount of power
they're taking there they don't need
two kilowatts they can use just 70 watts
per p4 card uh and so they're actually
39 times better in energy efficiency
which is shown in the darker green bar
chart here
how do different chips compare you say
oh the t4 is a little bit old you see
yeah but everybody wants to hear about
the t4 because they're used to that the
newer chip would be the a10 uh
and so that does a little bit better in
absolute performance about three times
better but it doesn't do as much better
in terms of of
energy efficiency in terms of
performance per watt okay
if you look at what esperanto can do
with this recommendation benchmark
we believe with our sick chips on our
card we'll get to roughly a factor of a
hundred times better
than those those eight
intel cpus would do in the system so
we're a great case where the customer
can still use the intel cpu on the host
to run the operating system to deal with
the i o but we're a good partner in
terms of being able to accelerate that
cpu by another factor of a hundred
so we're particularly good at deep
learning recommendation now at this
point in the presentation if we were
sitting in a in a consortium room
somebody would be raising their hand and
say yeah but i don't have this number in
my performance charts what do you do on
resnet50 so
okay yes we'll go we'll give that one
next because you all want to compare
that so we do uh again uh very well but
not 100x better we're about 25 times
better and that's probably because intel
spent a lot of time making resin
resonance 50 run well on their on their
advanced cpus as well
but overall and we we here were able to
we had a
habanagoya comparison for resnet50
whereas we didn't have that for dlrm
uh and we still do very very well with a
general purpose wrist five processor as
the the core of our acceleration here
okay uh it's a little bit on performance
now let's
got stuck there a little bit um
just talk about you know
we have a whole other class of processor
here our maxion processor here i'm not
going to spend a lot of time on this uh
it's an out of order processor we had
designed uh initially we started off
with the boom processor we more than
doubled its performance
uh
uh
and we have a number of other talks that
are out there just go look at one of
those other talks if you're interested
in the the maxion processor
uh again we think there will be
applications in the future that'll want
to run standalone and uh so uh the
maxions
it can run say uh i think we have them
running at about 1.5 gigahertz now in
the lab uh they can run a
linux operating system or something else
to to help drive the uh
the array of minions
uh so just some summary stats here um
uh it's found a tsmc 7 nanometer about
24 billion devices on a single die
uh it's only a moderate size die 570
millimeters squared
uh we're not going to the full reticle
size which is what or even wafer scale
size which is what other people are
doing is uh there are different
approaches that are appropriate for
different usage cases here
again three different types of
processors here
and typically for dlrm we're expecting
to operate these kind of around the 20
watt level or below
the the package
sorry the package here has got
about 2500 balls on the back of the
package
but there are many more bumps on the die
when you flip chip it over onto the
package we over 30 000 bumps what are we
doing with all those bumps well in
addition to lots of power and ground
one of the things we've done is to
realize that with a thousand processors
there is threshold voltage variation
across the die
or if you get unlucky enough that you
have a mass defect that you know maybe
the the processors in the lower
left-hand side of the die uh they're all
running a little bit slow
in order to get to the megahertz you
want you may have to turn up the voltage
uh to get there but all the rest of the
processors 90
we didn't need so much voltage
so each you can see in kind of the blue
squares here we have each group of 32
each of those group of 32 cpus has its
own independent
low voltage control
so we can finely tune the power supplies
to this and we think that can offer you
know tremendous power savings if you get
into issues where you have vte variation
again as the manufacturing proceeds and
matures over time maybe that's not quite
as critical but we have that flexibility
on dye
and we can also
use those to
you know again run different sections of
the chip at different frequencies there
are independent plls in each of those
groupings
uh so you can run different frequencies
different voltages you can have the
bottom half of the chip running
a recommendation half and maybe the top
half running a vision task again they're
just a thousand general purpose
processors programmers will figure out
what clever things they want to do with
these we've got a few uh
suggestions for machine learning but we
expect over time we're going to find all
kinds of clever uses for using a
thousand processors
okay so where are we at yeah well yes we
have real silicon
here's a picture of the wafer we have
chips up and running in the lab
we have a remote access for customers uh
for what we're doing here we're not in
general availability quite yet it takes
quite a long time to go through the
whole
qualification process on chips uh and
get everything finely tuned up but
everything is pretty much running on our
very first silicon here
we are still not seeing anything would
require not even a metal mass change on
the chip we're running uh substantial ai
inference workloads on all thousand plus
processors we're running nightly
continuous integration tests on those
the maxions are up and running
our pcie and ddr interfaces are up and
running at speed uh we have already done
a public demo uh
i think samsung
had a what they call a tech day they
were very impressed with what we were
doing and we showed how if you couple a
processor with an ssd that we can
dramatically reduce bandwidth
requirements in the system
uh so that's out and that's public um
and we're talking to individual large
customers at this point and we have an
early access program for those people to
get on and start testing our chip
if you're very very eager you can
contact us now and ask to be in the
early access program or later on this
year hopefully we'll have much more
widespread spread availability you can
get your own pcie card and play with it
so what's what's coming up next here so
that's let me just one slide there's a
lot of interesting things going on there
have been some announcements uh recently
here
so um
uh
uh last month less than a month ago on
february 7th uh esperanto announced that
we were partnering with intel uh to get
access to their advanced technology
nodes on their fab to their three
nanometer and uh 1.8 nanometer actually
they call it 18a generation
um and they also announced in addition
that esperanto was going to be one of
the risk five ecosystem partners
uh risk five is growing and intel has
just decided to go big into risk five
they've joined the risk five consortium
and they announced four different
ecosystem partners esperanto
andes and sci-fi who both offer
ip if you want to build your own uh
embedded chip and ventana microsystems
who is offering what they call a data
class center chip you'll have to talk to
them to see what they're doing
and esperanto is really focused more on
the ai side with over a thousand
ai optimized risk five cores we by far
have the highest uh performing risk five
system out there but that's just the
beginning
uh today
march 2nd there was an announcement some
of you may not have seen yet the
follow-on to the pcie bus in some ways
it's called the ucie bus
the universal chiplet interconnect
express was announced i think there were
about 20 different companies uh
announced so far here
they've announced basically a bus that
lets you connect uh chiplets together
um and so if you think of what we've
done in seven nanometer rather than
shrinking to five if you shrink directly
to three uh what we have is a thousand
processors and a moderate size chip
becomes a thousand processors and a
little tiny chiplet right
and with little tiny chiplets you might
assemble you know let's say 10 of those
on a package
maybe with even a zeon host cpu who
knows right and with a thousand each you
could put 10 thousand risk five pours
in in a fairly small package
uh with giblet technology here and so
the world is going to advance to where
you're not having hundred hundreds or
even just a thousand but tens of
thousands of cores able to operate
together
how do you program tens of thousands of
cores well we believe the general
purpose programming model is a really
good one and one that will scale because
the world has been scaling data centers
and other things to those kinds of
numbers of cpus in the past
so
again i'm not trying to announce any
particular product here but just to say
esperanto very much likes the chiplet
methodology and we like this special
packaging technology that intel has that
will help package chiplets
and so you should expect to see very
interesting things coming in the future
so i think i've kind of gone over most
of the details here we have this nice
scalable design
we're the stage we're at we're doing
early access for early customers right
now and yes we are hiring and growing go
ahead and see our website for details or
send me a personal email if you don't
see a slot there that that's made for
you and you want to do something else
tell us why you can contribute uh just
write that as a note along with your
resume we'd be happy to talk to you i
just want to say quick thanks to a
number of our different partners here
we've gotten ip from who've helped us
with the lab with packaging
uh with input on the design for what
they wanted as a large data scale
data center customers for debugging
hardware for uh for help particularly to
semi dynamics who's helped us with the
architecture
and other implementations we got going
to mobilize for the plls more tick for
some of the on-chip sensors
lots of different customers and a lot of
people have helped
again we see different companies and
risk five not as our competitors but as
members of a common ecosystem so thanks
also to sci-fi and andy's and other
companies there who we work together
with regularly in the ris5 consortia
out there uh again if you're interested
in some of the details here are the uh
the papers cited in the footnotes along
with a few more details here on how we
did the benchmarking
and at this point if dennis allows and
we can work out the logistics i'll take
a few questions i'm blown away i think
you did a great job with this thing i'm
really curious who the other who the
other architects were
this is a
significant departure from what
people have been doing and
i think you didn't done an exceptional
job
there were a lot of architects here and
a lot of people with a lot of industry
experience here we have some of the
original people just a personal thanks
to people like tom riordan who helped
found nips technologies um
uh alan baum
very involved in the instruction set and
helping us on risk five um you know
various other people brian you know well
brian case peter gloskowski others have
been helping uh
uh people who've uh started the spark
architecture started the mips
architecture we have a number of alpha
architects i think allen work bomb
worked on the alpha
sri masala who's one of the the top
floating point gurus in the world he did
the floating point on all the boxes he
did the floating point on the atonium he
worked for me on my secret project at
intel that i wish i could give you a
seminar about but we never got clearance
for that
um
uh and just a variety of different
people here we
we kind of bit off a very large problem
here and so we used a lot of people with
a lot of industry experience who came in
at the beginning and helped us out
and just want to say thanks to all of
those there are a lot of fairly
well-known names here and a lot of newer
people were training for the next
generation here we've got
well over 100 people
probably 150 to almost 200 people
contributed to this design in various
ways
directly working with esperanto okay so
we're giving out gold stars you've got
one uh no we can take some questions and
uh if you raise your hand and so forth
uh you should be able to do it got a
question
yeah the the uh of course the other big
problem in this space is training
any estimates on how you do on that or
is this purely inference
um we we are certainly capable with the
risk five instruction set to do some
training and we expect to do some
incremental training but training is a
really really hard problem and so when
we first went to the large data center
companies and said hey
we can build you a really good chip for
training
they
literally told us please don't do that
look we have over a million cpus in our
data center they have to be ready for
handling peak loads so what that means
is most of the time they're 50 idle we
don't care how long it takes to do
training we have plenty of cpu cycles
for training but we don't have is the
millisecond level response we need for
inference and so we were really guided
into doing more of an inference solution
to begin with again
i think training needs huge amounts of
memory you need to get to
there are just all kinds of very
challenging systems issues there so my
hat's off to the companies that are
going after training first
we decided to start with inference and i
think we'll grow into training as a
company more over time as i say we have
general purpose risk five processors
there's no reason why we can't do some
training the question will be do we have
enough memory for what you want to do
for your particular training if it fits
in 200 gigabytes and you can split the
work across six cores
yeah it's pretty easy to do and in fact
uh if you have a pcie bus system that
takes more than six slots we can kind of
add numbers of pcie cards and get the
collective memory up higher
or if you can just partition your
problem in a way yeah we could do
training that way but
one of the things they said is look if
you bring us a training chip it will
take well over a year
for us to go from buying you know a
dozen of your cpus to play with to where
we would understand how to uh deploy
this
um
so
and then how about more general high
performance computing problems
yes i think the big thing you'll notice
that's different at the moment at least
is the minions don't do double precision
floating point
but if your problem fits in single
precision or half precision or ant eight
go for it but uh it's great uh great
seeing so many people here just to email
me dave at esperanto.ai will get me and
would be happy to be in communication
but thanks everybody for coming it's
been a pleasure to be able to present
thank you dave it was really outstanding
to have you here
and we look forward to seeing you
in person at some point